what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and things are getting really really
exciting for the Marvel Cinematic
Universe lately we have had a lot of
crazy exciting news news that the
Fantastic 4 has begun pre-production
they are now testing the camera lenses
that they're going to use for the film
in preparation of shooting the actual
movie we are getting a lot of news about
Deadpool 3 and the old Fox characters
returning and cameo in that movie Plus
Loki season 2 is right around the corner
it is this week we are 5 days away
tomorrow I can do my social media
reaction and then Tuesday morning I can
give my review no spoilers I won't do
any spoilers but I will give you my
thoughts on the first four episodes of
Loki season 2 and of course we have a
recent announcement about the X-Men
movie it was announced by deadline that
Marvel Studios is getting ready to meet
with writers for a new X-Men film and
today we have even more information
about what Marvel studios's plans are
for this new X-Men movie and when we're
going to be getting this movie this has
been a Hot Topic lately because when
this movie comes out is going to greatly
determine and affect the story if it
comes out before Avengers Secret Wars
then obviously they're going to fit
somehow into the Multiverse Saga and
storyline and probably be a part of
Avengers Secret Wars then of course as
we talked about that raises the question
well what exactly happens to the X-Men
and the rest of the universe and the
Multiverse for that matter after Secret
Wars especially if they are indeed going
to be doing a soft reboot how will that
all fall into place but it looks like
they might actually be planning to do it
after Avengers Secret Wars which I think
a lot of people might actually prefer
sort of a fresh start for the X-Men not
connected really to any storyline we
have going on right now that way they
can be completely free with whatever
story they want to write for the new
X-Men but what do the fans think do you
all have a preference would you rather
the new X-Men team so we're not talking
about the old Fox X-Men coming in but a
new one with new characters and new
actors coming in would you like them to
come before Secret Wars and have them be
a part of that storyline or after once
the Multiverse Saga ends phase six ends
and we dive into phase seven let us know
what you'd prefer now here's what we
have recently heard and both of these
reports are coming from The Insider can
we get some toast and here's what they
said in reply to a tweet this was the
Tweet exclusive the wait is over with
the wga strike ending open writing
assignments are a big priority around
town and Marvel just set a big one as
their X-Men movie is finally starting
development as execs will meet with
writers this fall to hear pitches via
deadline who Justin croll who wrote this
is with and in response can we get some
toast said this this sounds exciting on
paper but it's actually not that
exciting if you consider how fige wants
the X-Men to appear in the MCU post
Avengers Secret Wars that's still four
plus years away and that is the truth if
they are indeed coming Post Secret Wars
which I believe is what Kevin feige's
plan is going to be we'll talk about why
in just a sec if it is Post Secret Wars
that's four plus years out right now
unfortunately due to the strikes kind of
all the future release dates are up in
the air right now they are subject to
change and even without the strikes they
could always change the release dates on
their own right now it's set for May 7th
of 2027 so that's where that four plus
years comes from we're in 2023 now in
four years we should get Avengers Secret
Wars fingers crossed and that's when the
X-Men will come and that is what can we
get some toast to stating right here
it's all very exciting that they're
starting to work on the X-Men movie and
working on bringing the X-Men into the
MCU unfortunately it's a long way away
but depending on how you look at this
this could be a really great thing if
you want Marvel Studios and the MCU to
be able to do whatever they want
story-wise with the X-Men in the m MCU
then having them come after Avengers
Secret Wars is the way to do it plus not
to mention we do have a lot coming
between now and Avengers Secret Wars a
lot will happen to hold us over plus we
are getting some X-Men and not just some
old X-Men but possibly new actors
playing old characters which will be
really cool to see who knows maybe Henry
caval will pop up as a wolverine variant
in Deadpool 3 anything's possible and I
really would love to see him in the MCU
even if it's just a little Cameo but
it's been made pretty clear that every
that we're going to see between now and
Avengers Secret Wars X-Men wise is
either just going to be a tease about
the New Mutants and X-Men that are going
to come like how they teased Miss Marvel
being a mutant or they are going to be
the original Fox X-Men characters making
cameos now another important thing that
can we get some toast tweeted out was
the current idea to reboot the X-Men in
the MCU does not feature Wolverine on
the team there's a reason why Marvel is
starting to push the X-Men so hard
across all mediums and will continue to
push them until they're on the big
screen and this is actually really
interesting and there is a really great
reason that Marvel Studios would do this
and we'll talk about that in just a bit
but first big thank you to hellofresh
for sponsoring this video many of you
may know that I personally use
hellofresh and I love it it makes
cooking fun easy and it's affordable and
that's why it's America's number one
meal kit delivered straight to your door
and you might not know that they
actually have seasonal recipes right now
since it's summer they have their new
fresh and fit summer menu so if you're
trying to get that beach bud but you're
also trying to eat really great tasting
food it's perfect for you right now it's
peak time for summer produce and
hellofresh make sure you get all the
best picks all season long their
ingredients travel from the farm to your
door in less than 7 days for Quality you
can taste if you are trying to impress
your friends this summer by doing some
cooking for them hellofresh makes it
super simple they give you all of the
ingredients and tell you exactly how to
make each meal and the best part is
right now you can go to hellofresh.com
Cosmic and use code 50 Cosmic for 50%
off plus 15% off the next two months
that's hellofresh.com sl50 Cosmic and
use code 50 Cosmic for 50% off plus 15%
off the next two
months now the reason that Marvel
Studios is going to do this not really
have a heavy focus on Wolverine right
away in the MCU is because the X-Men are
a huge Ensemble it is not just Wolverine
yes the fox X-Men movies did make
Wolverine the face of that universe and
the face of the X-Men and that was fine
it was iconic it was great and there
were a lot of amazing characters in that
franchise besides Wolverine as well and
everybody is super looking forward to
Hugh Jackman returning as Wolverine and
going into the Marvel Cinematic Universe
of course however there are so many
other amazing characters that are a part
of the X-Men in the comics plus not to
mention Wolverine is not a part of the
original X-Men Xmen team and can we get
some toast even posted a picture of the
original X-Men comic cover and a lot of
us have even recently been talking about
how Marvel Studios might try to do an
X-Men first Class for their first
storyline for the X-Men and mutants in
the MCU we talked about this in pretty
good detail yesterday in our podcast so
be sure to check that out but can we get
some toast also implies that the X-Men
first Class team might be the ones that
we see in the MCU at first and that's
going to be fantastic having a focus on
Cyclops on Iceman Jing gray Angel who is
also named Warren and some other amazing
Heroes then we have to go down the route
of the weapon x program that is a whole
story on its own that could be multiple
movies built up to Wolverine but they
should take their time telling that
story which is another reason why
Wolverine shouldn't just come into the
MCU on the new X-Men team right away
because they should tell the story of
The Weapon X Program which I believe
they are actually about to do in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe we're about to
see some of this start to happen in
Captain America Brave New World and the
Thunderbolts we know that tyut island is
going to have adenium which is of course
what Wolverine's medal is so I think
we're about to see the beginning here
for the Weapon X Program in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe which will ultimately
bring in Logan Wolverine but it does
sound like there is going to be an
established X-Men team before he makes
his way into the MCU as a part of that
team plus not to mention Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine is going to get a lot of SP
light in Deadpool 3 and some other
projects in the Multiverse Saga Kevin
Fig's plan is to focus on those original
Fox X-Men characters bringing them into
the Marvel Cinematic Universe so they
can be a part of this universe that
didn't exist back in the 2000s and then
say goodbye and remember Kevin fogy
worked on those X-Men films he was an
associate producer in 2000 he's been
with Marvel a long time so to be able to
bring these old friends of his their
characters into the MCU and give them a
proper goodbye that's where he's at
right now and I think it sounds sounds
like a great plan right before we get
the new X-Men but go ahead and let me
know your thoughts about all of this in
the comments down below what do you
think should be the first X-Men
storyline and who do you think should be
on the first X-Men team let us know down
below we are also starting a new monthly
giveaway all you got to do to enter
subscribe to the channel and leave a
comment down below the winner gets to
pick between an Xbox series X A PS5 some
Marvel Legends items or some DC items
they pick one item and we pick one
winner at the end of each month don't
forget to like the video and you can
find us on Instagram and Twitter as well
well as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
woof